WE'RE ON THE ROAD BEFORE
SUNRISE, QUICKLY REALIZING WE
CAN ALREADY SPOT OUR DESTINATION
SOME 30 MILES OUT.
THERE YOU SEE IT.
THAT RED-ORANGE GLOEW, MAUNA LO
ERUPTING.
TO GIVE YOU A BETTER VIEW, WE GO
UP IN THE MORNING DARK.
PARADISE HELICOPTERS DARYN
HAMILTON, OUR PILOT AND GUIDE,
GIVING US RARE ACCESS.
>> WE SEE THE VOLCANO, JUST OFF
THE EASTERN SIDE THERE AT ABOUT
THE 1:00 POSITION.
>> Reporter: HAVING FLOWN IN
MILITARY HOT ZONES, DARYN EVEN
ADMITS THIS IS FIRE POWER LIKE
NO OTHER.
>> WHAT WAS IT LIKE THE FIRST
TIME WITH OPEN LAVA?
>> IT WAS A BLAST.
>> Reporter: IT CAN ALSO BE
CHALLENGING, ESPECIALLY WITH
HEAVY FOG OR VOLCANIC SMOG.
>> YOU CAN SEE THE GASES FROM
FISSURE THREE.
>> THOSE ACID TICK GASES
DANGEROUS IF THE CONCENTRATIONS
ARE TOO HIGH.
ON THE GROUND OFFICIALS WATCHING
THE IMPACT ON SADDLE ROAD, THE
MAIN HIGHWAY THAT CONNECTS THE
EAST AND WEST OF THE ISLAND.
ERUPTING LAST SUNDAY FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN 38 YEARS, MAUNA
LOA, THE WORLD'S LARGEST ACTIVE
VOLCANO IS ONE OF FIVE THAT MAKE
UP HAWAII'S BIG EYE HAND.
NEIGHBORING KILAUEA ALSO ACTIVE,
THAT NO LONGER SHOOTING LAVA TO
THE SURFACE LIKE IT DID IN 2013.
>> WE'RE ON THE STREET WHERE MY
HOUSE WAS AT.
IT'S THAT WAY, ON THE OPPOSITE
SIDE OF THE SUBDIVISION.
>> Reporter: DOROTHY INVITES US
TO WHERE HER HOME NOW SITS,
BURIED UNDER 60 FEET OF LAVA.
YOU CAN SEE A METAL STREET LIGHT
FUSED IN.
>> WHEN YOU HAVE SOMETHING LIKE
THIS, YOU'RE ALL DISBURSED AFTER
THAT.
>> YEAH.
WE LOST THAT SENSE OF COMMUNITY
IN ADDITION TO THE HOMES.
>> Reporter: AN EMOTIONAL
TRIGGER FOR DOROTHY AND OTHERS,
FORCING THE DRAMA FROM KILAUEA
BACK TO THE SURFACE.
THE 2018 LAVA FLOW WIPED OUT
MORE THAN 600 HOMES HERE, SOME
UNTOUCHED, BUT LEFT LAVA LOCKED,
AN ISLAND WITHIN THE ISLAND.
DOROTHY SHOWED US THIS VIDEO SHE
CAPTURED A FEW WEEKS BACK,
HELPING FRIENDS GATHER THE LAST
OF THEIR BELONGINGS FROM THEIR
HOME.
THE REMINDERS OF DEVASTATION
HERE HARD TO MISS.
>> THIS IS THE HOME.
THEY'VE EVACUATED THE SECOND
NIGHT.
AND I BELIEVE IT WENT UNDER THE
THIRD NIGHT.
>> AND JUST TOOK THEIR HOME.
>> TOOK THEIR HOME.
>> FOUR YEARS LATER IT'S STILL
STEAMING.
>> STILL STEAMING.
>> HOW LONG WILL IT STEAM LIKE
THAT?
>> PROBABLY 30 TO 40 YEARS.
>> HOW IS IT THAT YOU CAN STILL
CEBUITY AFTER SO MUCH LOSS?
>> BECAUSE LAVA IS BEAUTIFUL.
IT'S PAY LEE'S CREATION.
THAT'S HOW THE ISLAND WAS
FORMED, HOW IT WAS BUILT.
>> Reporter: AN APPRECIATION
SHARED BY NATIVE HAWAIIANS.
THOUSANDS OF TOURISTS AND LOCALS
ARRIVING AFTER SUNSET TO WITNESS
THE LAVA GLOW.
NIGHTTIME TRAFFIC BACKS UP TO
MILES.
TO AVOID THE CONGESTION, LET'S
GET BACK TO THE SKIES.
>> 2,000 TO 3,000 DEGREES
FAHRENHEIT OR 1,000 DEGREES
CELSIUS.
THAT'S MOLTEN ROCK FLOWING LIKE
WATER.
>> Reporter: WHICH HAS ALREADY
CROSSED ONE VOLCANO ROAD, POWER
LINES AND ALL, A SEARING SLICE
RIGHT THROUGH IT.
>> THE HEAT YOU FEEL AS SOON AS
YOU GET CLOSE TO IT.
>> LOOK AT THE RUSHING FLOW, THE
RIVER.
YOU CAN SEE THE CURRENT OF LAVA.
>> Reporter: DARYN ESTIMATES
IT'S MOVING 30 TO 40 MILES PER
HOUR.
>> THE SOURCE OF IT ALL, THERE'S
NOTHING LIKE THIS.
JUST SPEWING FROM THE TOP.
THAT 30 TO 40 MILES PER HOUR
HAPPENING ABOUT 15 MILES FROM
US, WAY UP THERE.
DOWN HERE, DON AND POPPY, IT'S
MOVING AT ABOUT 40 FEET PER
HOUR, SO MUCH SLOWER BECAUSE
IT'S FANNING OUT, BUT STILL
INCHING CLOSER TO THE ROADWAY.
JUST OVER TWO MILES FROM THAT
MAIN HIGHWAY.
IT WAS ENTERING OVERNIGHT THEY
HAD TO SHOT DOWN THIS PORTION OF
THE VIEWING AREA BECAUSE OUT
HERE ON THE LAVA ROCK FROM PAST
ERUPTIONS THERE WAS AN
UNEXPLODED ORDINANCE THAT WAS
FOUND.
THEY'RE ASKING FOLKS PULL OVER,
DON'T WALK ONTO THE LAVA ROCK.
FOR THAT REASON WE'RE KEEPING A
BIT CLOSER TO THE ROADWAY.
>> LEAVE IT TO DAVID CULVER TO
GIVE US THE MOST REMARKABLE
VIEW --
>> POPPY LIVE COMMENTING.
>> I SAID DURING THE PIECE, HE'S
SUCH A GOOD WRITER.
>> THANKS, DAVID.
>> THANK YOU.